et la langue française à nos nouveautés
et maltraité
par christiane taubira et son équipe sur
son propre compte twitter regarder
malheureusement voilà vous n'avez pas
fini c'est quand vous voulez madame
taubira voilà vous avez vu la faute
d'orthographe
celle-ci lui la voix sait que c'est
grave alors c'est vrai que si le
président emmanuel macron a la chance
d'avoir une prof de français avec lui
pour tout relire ce n'est visiblement
pas le cas pour christiane taubira est
bien bonne nouvelle sachez que ça a
donné une idée de jeu à france 2
regardez c'est le rouge
après le jeu motus découvrez le toto
dérape les pme doivent ils être sans la
bonne orthographe et c'est gagné la
gencive j am
sgr
pas mieux commencer agenda h à j y
ndd à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taubira pour une france sans chômage et
son échelle
du cac derrière les boîtes de nuit
aujourd'hui perso j'ai déjà préparé ma
petite tenue pour ce soir et à cette
occasion les jeunes avec mac ont réalisé
un petit clip pour inciter à aller voter
regardez et voilà et donc eh bien
figurez vous que depuis l'annnonce de la
réouverture des boîtes de nuit tous les
candidats se sont rués pour aller se
trémousser regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non seulement
les autres aides à commencer bien sûr la
victoire du paris saint germain hier
soir mais visiblement eric zemmour
préféré mater autre chose regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr bien sûr certaines vannes eric
zemmour et son équipe ont vraiment
regardé le match et on a fait une
réunion regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les chefs vous nous montrez une
petite rigolade c'est que jean luc
mélenchon a tenté un nouveau look avec
de nouvelles lunettes regardez c'est pas
une vanne regardez voilà les nouvelles
lunettes validé bungie tu vois là il
sachez qu avant d'opter pour cette perte
il n'en a essayé quelques-unes il a par
exemple essayez lunettes de vue ou
j'entends ont gardé
et là aussi si ces lunettes regardez
ici également les lunettes castaldi mais
à mon avis boyer pas grand chose
regarder
voilà et malheureusement je vous le dis
c'est la mort dans l'âme que je vous
annonce qu anne hidalgo ne voudrais pas
participer à face à papa
le seul problème c'est qu'on l'a pas
invité dans face à base d'algues on
l'avait invitée dans tpm p1 voulait pas
on n'allait pas voilà vous voulez pas
l'inviter dans face à bah on a enquêté
pour savoir pourquoi elle ne voulait pas
venir et c'est vrai avoue anne hidalgo a
une très bonne excuse
le tpm pays de face à baye situé à
boulogne la mairie de paris dans le 1er
arrondissement pour venir chez ba ba on
doit donc prendre la rue de rivoli
problème elle est désormais en sens
unique anne va donc prendre un quai de
seine mais elle ne peut pas c'est devenu
une voie cyclable elle va donc se
diriger vers la butte montmartre mais
elle est limitée à 30 km heure comme le
père était boucher 22 heures par jour à
cause de travaux dans paris elle va
passer par le sud en empruntant
l'autoroute a71 puis l'a75 en direction
de montpellier là bas elle prend 1,8 bus
pour revenir vers le sud de paris à
porte d'orléans elle doit louer un
tuk-tuk à pédales direction porte de
saint cloud elle finit donc en footing
de 45 minutes avec deux arrêts de
ravitaillement selon les calculs de wise
il faudrait donc qu'à d'hidalgo quatre
mois deux semaines six jours et 4 heures
pour relier le centre de paris à
boulogne l arrivée de m
[Applaudissements]
fermer ce point de campagne je voulais
aussi vous montrer quelques rigolade
qu'on a vu passe à la radio dans les
matinales politique regardez c'est parti
l approche de la présidentielle les
interviews politiques s'enchaînent dans
les matinales radio mais à force de
passer autant de temps sur un bateau il
commence à se croire un petit peu chez
eux
bonjour l'idée fort
reine boira pas donc comment ça comment
ça va
alors on connaît tous désormais le
scandale des ehpad mais pour françois
ruffin il ya un autre scandale dont on
ne parle pas assez les maisons de
retraite c'est un rationnement y compris
sur les gâteaux de pépito ont goûté il
ya qu un seul gâteau de pépito on donne
pas deux trois gâteaux c'est pas lourd à
gâteaux de pépito chaque euro qui
étaient versées en dividende c'est des
pépites au à l'autre pépite
sur france 2 jean castex et épouse en
train d'échanger avec les français et je
prends bien qu'il avait un message à
faire passer on va parler pouvoir
d'achat avec les français qui sont là
aussi moins clairement
vraiment ça me révolte je passe tous les
jours sur mon trajet devant une station
essence
[Musique]
vous êtes satisfait de la réponse pas
forcément bon si ça a pas l'air d'aller
pour jean castex en revanche en a pour
qui tout roule visiblement bonjour
fabien roussel bonjour léa salamé
bonjour ni la demande et aux jours
heureux je revendique le droit au
bonheur et je dis même que le bonheur
c'est le comptage et le communisme c'est
le bonheur donc pour vous je veux des
réformes heureuse je veux croire au
bonheur parce que c'est possible 50 ciel
bleu regardez ça s'ouvre enfin yab
l'horizon jean michal est elle c'est
beau ça
[Applaudissements]
m